là monsieur bonsoir aujourd'hui encore
la ville de beyrouth et sa banlieue les
villages de la montagne au sud de la
capitale libanaise ont vécu au survécu
au rythme des bombardements les combats
entre l'armée régulière libanaise et les
ministres russes se poursuivre même si
l'arabie saoudite avec le soutien des
états unis tentent d'oeuvrer pour un
cessez le feu dans les villages
chrétiens de la montagne encerclé depuis
plusieurs jours par les milices druzes
la situation est de plus en plus
critique surtout à deir el qamar où se
sont réfugiés près de trente mille
chrétiens pour la première fois une
équipe de télévision celle d'antenne 2 a
réussi aujourd'hui atteindre dr el kamar
en exclusivité le reportage de patricia
cost et de philippe péters on nous à
vide ils font sauter à l'eba made man
était sur notre tête
r en moins garni y aller nous sommes
nous nous sommes sentis un papier tient
bien bien rien au monde ses lignes
arrières me semblait misérable très très
peur
oh ils sont pris au piège
ils croient qu'ils vont tous mourir sous
les obus des druzes qui encercle ce
village trente mille personnes en otages
trente mille femmes enfants vieillards
et combattant phalangistes ils ont fui
leurs villages chrétiens de la montagne
devant le rouleau compresseur de
l'avancée de ruse pour venir sans passer
ici à deir el qamar il pensait y être
protégés par les 2000 phalangistes posté
dans ce bourg ces hommes sont
aujourd'hui des soldats vaincu et leur
chef le célèbre samir geagea
responsables chrétiens pour tous le chou
est lui aussi prisonnier de guerre dans
un couvent au dessus il ne voudra pas
qu'on le fil second n'était pas prêt à
recevoir tous ces réfugiés
ils se sont installés un peu partout
comme dans cette église notre arrivée la
première équipe de télévision qui voit
suscitera des cris des hurlements de
colère et de désespoir car est l'auteur
d'un massacre
pour l'instant les canons se sont tus
une trêve fragile et observer
entre assiégée et assiégeant des messes
sont dit toute la journée et la nuit de
non plus que cela à faire
trieux
un hôpital du bourg sont soignés une
centaine de bus fait beaucoup de
combattants au regard vide sans un
sourire l'hôpital manque de tout et
surtout de sérum et d'analgésiques
ce jeune homme avec son chapelet autour
du cou est amputé d'une jambe prisonnier
d'un hôpital de fortune sous les canons
des druzes tout autour on avait parlé de
cas de choléra chez des enfants
en fait ils ont surtout des diarrhées et
des maladies cutanées dues au manque
d'hygiène
il n'y a plus que deux points d'eau dans
le village aujourd'hui un petit espoir
est revenu à deir el qamar avec les
rumeurs de l'arrivée de la croix rouge
mais autour de la ville otages la guerre
n'est pas finie la peur reste tapi les
chrétiens n'ont aucune confiance dans
les truffes qui nous ont pourtant
autorisé à venir les filmer parce que je
n'ai pas d'amis ici
mais qu'est ce qu'on va faire s'ils vont
tirer en reste on regarde les vallées et
les balles viennent chez l'eau
on va lutter une autre derrière c'est
l'autre de la chance on va le faire et
on trouvera 14
devant cette situation j'insiste
j'insiste et à sauver les enfants qui
vont mourir de faim et il n'y a pas
d'eau jusqu'à mais non monsieur vous